Negative 10y to the 4th plus 8y cubed is the correct answer. That's some great
work if you got it correct. If you got stuck somewhere, stay with me and then
pause it when you find a mistake and then keep going. This question involved
exponents and a negative term, so there are a couple of places where you might
have gotten tripped up. I'm going to list this factor, 2y squared, on one side
of a rectangle, then I'm going to have 4y, and negative 5y squared on the other
side of my rectangle. I'm going to consider this a positive region, because I
have a positive number times a positive number. I shaded this region orange,
because we're going to wind up with a positive number, here's a positive times a
positive. For this region I've shade it grey because we have a negative number
times a positive number, we'll wind up with a negative area here. 2y squared
times positive 4y is 8y cubed. Next I have 2y squared times negative 5y squared,
I'm finding the area of this part of my rectangle. I know a negative area might
not make sense, but you can think about this area as the area that you have and
this area, about the area that you owe. We use our properties of numbers to
multiply 2 and negative 5, and our properties of exponents to get negative 10y
to the fourth. Finally, we reverse the order or the two terms, to get our final
answer. Negative 10y to the 4th should be our first term, and positive 8y to the
3rd should come second. Keep in mind, the signs in front of the terms stay with
them.